I turned to my kids and I was like you
are half Ukrainian half a mayor like I
literally was like look you and my kids
were like yeah Mom I get it and I was
like no you are Ukrainian and American
Mila Kunis is opening up about why it's
important for her kids to know about
their Ukrainian Roots all amid Russia's
invasion of her home country so your
parents is that true they had 250 they
came here yep but my mom my dad my
brother myself my grandpa my grandmother
my other grandfather 250 bucks for the
family
1991. the actress who immigrated from
Ukraine to the U.S when she was nine
years old reveals there was a time when
she told people she was from Russia and
Mila explains to Maria Shriver on her
conversations above the Noise series she
had her reasons why when I came to the
states and I would tell people I'm from
Ukraine the first question I would get
is where's Ukraine and then I'd have to
explain Ukraine and where it is on the
map and I was like oh that's exhausting
but if I was like I'm from Russia people
are like oh we know that country like
every instantly people were like I know
that red dot and so I was like wait I'll
just tell people I'm from Russia but
even from an early age Mila says she
felt like she was La through and through
after immigrating to California in 1991.
I very much have always felt like an
American there's no part of me that ever
people were like oh you're so Eastern
European I was like I'm so L.A however
in the midst of Russia invading her
Homeland Mila says she felt a massive
shift this happens and I can't express
or explain what like what came over me
but all of a sudden I genuinely hope I
was like oh my God I feel like a part of
my heart just got ripped out it was the
weirdest
feeling and more than ever the Black
Swan star wants her kids to know the
importance of their Heritage I turned to
my kids and I was like you are half
Ukrainian half America like I literally
was like look you and my kids were like
yeah Mom I get it and I was like no you
are Ukrainian and American I was like
you're half Iowa half Ukraine and
they're like okay I get it and now Mila
and her husband Ashton Kutcher are doing
what they can to help the events that
have unfolded in Ukraine are devastating
there is no place in this world for this
kind of unjust attack on Humanity we're
raising funds to support a relief effort
that will have immediate impact and
Supply much needed Refugee and
humanitarian Aid to the area their goal
raising 30 million dollars to support
those affected by the conflict after
just a few days they're more than
halfway there we have raised over 20
million dollars in less than a week and
I say we because it's all of us together
we do want to say say thank you to the
56 000 of you who were able to donate
and supported us and whether it was the
five dollars or ten dollars the one
thousand dollars whatever it was means
so much to us because it does bring in a
community and a sense of belonging and
an ability to help